plans are already being made to rebuild
notre-dame Cathedral in Paris less than
48 hours after it was devastated by fire
about 1 billion dollars has been
promised to help restore one of France's
best known symbols Roxana Suvari is
outside Notre Dom in the heart of Paris
Roxana good morning
good morning the local newspaper the
Papazian is reporting that a fire alarm
went off here at notre-dame Cathedral
shortly after 6:00 p.m. on Monday but a
computer bug showed the fires location
in the wrong place the paper is also
reporting the flames may have started at
the bottom of the spire and may have
been caused by an electrical problem in
an elevator nutri Dom stands damaged but
defiant after a fire that raged for at
least 12 hours leaving a gaping hole in
its heart inside where the spire
collapsed in Monday night's fire the
altar is buried in debris but it's cross
is almost shining and pews are still in
place these other rescued artifacts were
taken to Paris City Hall paintings
chairs armchairs and objects you know
candle holders and it was it was
absolutely extraordinary because it's a
miracle you know what save here
saved the French government says by
brave firefighters who risked their
lives to fight the flames nous sommes
French president Emmanuel Medical hailed
them as heroes and vowed to rebuild the
eighth century old cathedral within five
years there's still some features of
architectural historian Tricia Meehan
tells us the time it takes to restore
the Gothic cathedral depends on the
extent of the damage if in the end the
stone structure has been compromised
that's a whole other ballgame how long
could that take to rebuild if they even
decide to rebuild it it would take a
really long time because we're talking
about a lot of hand labor so decades
yeah
as France mourns many people here are
praying that however long it takes
nutria Dom will rise again and
cathedrals across the country to show
solidarity plan to ring their bells
tonight marking 48 hours since the fire
began Catholic leaders here hope the
bells will be heard beyond Frances
borders just as season the devastation
here have resonated across the world
Nora Kevin Dean Roxana Saberi in Paris
thank you